Whether it's introducing an iconic character,
creating a mind-blowing battle, or surprising
fans with the unexpected, first impressions
are key to a successful superhero cinematic
universe.
With that in mind, let's take a look at some
of the genre's greatest opening scenes.
Batman
These days, Batman is everywhere, but in 1989,
comic book fans were still waiting for the
Dark Knight take over the silver screen.
They were also ready for something darker
than TV's Batman; something that felt more
like the comics written by Alan Moore and
Frank Miller.
Director Tim Burton was able to impress even
the most diehard fans with his Gothic take
on Gotham City in this opening scene—a city
cloaked in darkness, with buildings that looked
like they'd been designed by a drunken Fritz
Lang.
Enter, Batman.
Two thugs, having recently mugged a family,
are busy counting their ill-gotten cash when
But bullets can't stop Batman.
And then we get to hear the most iconic superhero
line of all time
"What are you?"
"I'm batman."
Just like that, a cinematic hero is born.
Blade
Long before the MCU existed, there was 1998's
Blade: the first successful Marvel movie.
Directed by Stephen Norrington, the film’s
opening fight scene was hailed by critics
as "the best set piece in comic book history."
A man is lured inside the world's nastiest
nightclub by a beautiful woman, and we witness
his revulsion as he realizes the ceiling is
rigged with blood-spurting sprinklers.
Then they start baring fangs, and we realize
this poor sap is about to become dinner.
But before the feast begins, in comes a sword-wielding
superhero: the half-human, half-vampire Blade,
played by Wesley Snipes.
He stakes, blasts and cuts with an impressive
array of weapons.
This opening grabs your attention right off
the bat.
Spider-Man 2
What makes Tobey Maguire's Spider-Man so relatable
is that underneath the costume, he’s just
an ordinary guy with ordinary problems.
Directed by Sam Raimi, the film finds Peter
Parker on the verge of losing his job at a
pizza restaurant.
With only seven and a half minutes to make
a career-saving delivery, Peter changes into
his Spidey suit.
"He stole that guy's pizzas!"
Of course, Spider-Man can’t help but rescue
some kids from oncoming truck, but he loses
his job when he delivers the pizzas late.
Being super isn't all it's cracked up to be,
especially when you're broke, lonely, and
tired of saving everyone but yourself.
The Dark Knight
The opening to 2008's The Dark Knight is one
of the all-time greats.
Filmed on 70mm IMAX, Christopher Nolan’s
masterpiece begins with a creeping score that
warns us something's up... just before a bunch
of thugs wearing clown masks kick off an elaborate
heist.
They take over a bank, bantering about the
Joker, their enigmatic boss.
As they work, they pick each other off, one
by one, until there's only one thug standing.
Before he can get away, an injured mob enforcer
asks him:
"Honor… respect.
Look at you?
What do you believe in, huh?"
That's when the clown pulls off his mask to
reveal the horrific face of the Joker.
The Clown Prince of Crime has been there the
whole time!
As he prepares to make his getaway, he delivers
his chilling credo:
"I believe whatever doesn't kill you makes
you stranger."
Watchmen
Say what you want about the movie as a whole,
but there's no denying that the opening to
Zack Snyder’s Watchmen perfectly captures
the bloody beat-down of Alan Moore's graphic
novel.
We open on the Comedian, a so-called superhero
who's done more dirty deeds than derring-do.
The grizzled nihilist is alone, contemplating
life's many sick jokes, when a mysterious
opponent storms into the room.
"Just a matter of time I suppose."
As the shadowy assassin beats the Comedian
into oblivion, Snyder employs his trademark
slow-mo.
The entire fight is underscored by Nat King
Cole's "Unforgettable," and as the Comedian
is tossed out the window, we're left with
an opening no superhero fan will ever forget.
Deadpool
We all know that Deadpool doesn't play by
the rules, and neither does the opening of
his R-rated blockbuster.
Who would've thought that a movie about a
deformed mutant assassin would open with Juice
Newton's "Angel of the Morning"?
The song plays as the camera winds through
a suspended tableau of destruction, while
the hilarious credits tell us to watch out
for "God's Perfect Idiot," a "Hot Chick,"
and a "British Villain."
Of course, the awesomeness doesn't stop there.
Immediately after the credits, we see the
Merc with a Mouth perched on an overpass,
jamming to "Shoop".
Deadpool breaks the fourth wall to say hello
to the audience
"Oh Oh Hello."
before jumping off the overpass and landing
in an SUV full of villains.
We get to watch the slow-mo credits play out
in real time, gory and hysterically over-the-top.
It sets the perfect tone for the madness to
follow.
"Did i leave the stove on?"
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2
When your 2017 movie starts with a 1980s Kurt
Russell, you know you're doing something right.
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 opens with
Ego the Living Planet and Meredith Quill cruising
down back roads of Missouri.
We’re caught up in the romance of it all—not
to mention the amazing digital work done on
Russell's face.
The lazy afternoon doesn't last long, though.
"showtime a-holes"
34 years into the future, everyone’s favorite
a-holes are preparing for battle and, as you
can expect, bickering.
"My nipples hurt oh goodness me"
When an oversized space squid comes tearing
out of the sky, the ensuing fight is accompanied
by Electric Light Orchestra blasting on the
stereo.
Baby Groot dancing to ELO is possibly the
most adorable scene in the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe—one that took two whole years of
planning.
Really, the only thing better than watching
Baby Groot boogie is watching director James
Gunn choreograph all the dance moves.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!